today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way
to the beach gray block get that hitter
get it for yourselves get it for
somebody else how's your fantasy squad
doing huh how's your team dude you got
sterling sharp ha ha that dude ain't
getting it done but with some other
people that aren't aren't you got
sterling sharp you got how is somebody
not named mustard I feel like I feel
like there has to be an NFL player named
mustard at some point I look that up NFL
mustard man
no mail player and I felt mustard
Chad mustard he was a tight end boy he
was signed by the Omaha beef as a free
agent in 2003 he played college football
and college basketball in North Dakota
Oh Chad mustard dang has got any more
than that huh
fool well you got to respect that boy um
fantasy teams yeah my team is doing well
decent alright is there you think is
there any bigger fantasy team than then
human beings you think then humanity is
there any bigger
is there any bigger you know the powers
above putting us in here put slotting us
in here here trying this trying that
this wild times you know
the times are getting thick especially
uh yeah nature's just getting real thick
right now you could taste it in the air
if you even just just lick the air a
little do it nobody will see you
and if they do I'll tell you this if
they see you do it they're gonna do it
they're gonna think something's going on
try it lick the air once or twice gotta
taste it in your mouth
something's happening there's getting
thick we're all on a fantasy team I
don't know what's going on sometimes
it's wild I think it's that time of year
you know I was talking about it last
week and it's just the universe is thick
right now with with people coming and
going you know with Halloween here and
with it's just that time of year where
all the escalators are active and all
the TSA lanes are open to come and go
here into the netherworld and it's um
it's who we are in one heck of a fantasy
game aren't we
let's go
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been now I'm just floating on the breeze
and not feeling like these leaves I must
be its gonna tell you guys
little time for me to sell their pocket
break and let my
[Music]
yeah yes and that is something that can
save us right there music and the other
thing that can save us is the light of
something bigger the light of something
bigger than a Senate shining on us then
it wants to see us I do believe that I
do believe that the good wants us to win
I do believe that men and wants to see
our faces and it wants us to know that
it accepts us that we don't have to hide
that we don't have to be ashamed you
know sometimes maybe that's even why
ghosts come and see us because they're
trying to say hey hey hey buddy you got
you don't need all this extra you don't
need all of this pomp and circumstance
and all these French coats and all of
these mink hats and mink shoes and
everything and all the exotic taffy and
everything you just need you
and we just need each other and you're
gonna be okay
sometimes uh yeah I just I think that
the that this is the time when the you
know you could hang as much drywall as
you want and you cannot stop the spirits
from peeking back you cannot stop the
light from looking down it's a
thoroughfare right now brother it is a
it's the Autobahn and what if this is
this is what if this is just the middle
ground you know what if this is just the
me this is just the lobby between Satan
and the Lord and that's that between the
good and evil this is just a doctor's
office this is just the there's just
magazines sitting around here in our
world it really is
we really are we're just milling around
looking at magazines here waiting to be
called in a different direction but I
believe that I believe that this is the
time when you know el Dia de los Muertos
you know when the devil's you know he's
got as many ARMs as he can and he's
reaching them up and the light is
looking down and it is just this
sabotage right now welcome to this past
weekend and yeah I'm just I guess I got
a lot on my mind right now just I think
just about purpose I've been thinking
about a lot this week you know and who
do I want to be you know just as a human
Who am I you know who don't want to be
as a man you know does my manhood matter
as much as my human hood if that makes
any sense I've been thinking about that
a little you know I've been thinking
about that you know sometimes we get
bottled we get directed into so many
things especially when we were young I
notice for myself I get directed in this
way and directed in that and it really
frames it helps to kind of like form the
way I think and feel and also
compartmentalize me you know and so I've
just been I guess I don't know it's that
time of year where even our chakras and
our hearts and our treasure chests and
our dam you know our dirty clothes
hamper x' and the recycling bins inside
of us there it's all open it's that open
door policy right now you know the full
moon is building up and in you know and
it always said it's just a anything can
come in anything can go and there's just
a lot of energy milling around the
moment and I know that because I'm
feeling it I'm feeling it I'm feeling it
for my friends and I'm feeling it from
even my non friends you know I'm just
feeling it
so good to be here thank you guys for
coming back thank I hope you're having a
good day you know I hope you're having a
good day and let's get into the episode
I do want to let you know that they have
um it's not an ad everybody thought I
was gonna be an ad right there
but yet going ahead when we're talking
to lick the air a little lick the air
just a little if you do it serious
enough and don't act like a donkey while
you're doing it then the man seeing you
down the way or the lady or the you know
you know anybody that's home own and
down the way whoever they are they will
do it as well they're gonna do cuz
that's the thing we're so susceptible
like are they what are they doing did
they know something I don't
oh is there free vanilla in the air
today what's happening oh maybe the
Lord's just emptying out his pantry and
everybody's catching a free head of huh
you know maybe somebody's catching free
um you know a free ought a fee maybe the
Lord through some Taffy's off of the
floor and they've fallen into people's
faces and everything who knows
maybe somebody you know you got to get
your tongue out of your mouth man and
catch something that's what I'm saying
it's that time of year um I have a show
announcement do i yes I don't know when
the tickets going to be on sale December
26th in Lafayette Louisiana at the Hyman
Performing Arts Center some proceeds
from the evening are going to benefit
Dustin Poirier is the good fight
foundation you know and uh we're excited
about that you know you can follow me on
social medias for the presale code and
yeah we're excited help raise money for
Dustin's for for the good fight
foundation and I think it's gonna be a
fun time of year it's gonna be a fun
time of year and I'm hoping to be able
to be there and and be a part of
people's holiday season so afterwards
Dustin and I as well might you know do
some photos and everything with anybody
that wants them he'll most people
probably don't want him we might have to
chase you down to get you to do one with
us but you know I believe that he's a
good guy and I believe that he fights
for people that can't and so does this
charity and I'm excited to be down there
in the laughy they call it the left hand
Lafayette and it's a big place I don't
even know what that place was I don't
know if we'll sell it out or not but
it's a big place uh what's going on with
me I am oh I've been watching what is it
I've been watching righteous gemstone
boy it's good I just I think the number
one costume this year gonna be uncle
baby Billy's you know it
and uncle baby abilities and he got that
little big suit big tufa side piece you
know that [ __ ] little enamel snake
he's got always slithering around with
them Tiffany or something her name is
Tabitha
uncle baby of La ha so that's beautiful
I wonder if it'd be fun to have him and
I maybe we get Keefe in here that other
guy with the long hair that Satan boy
and he loves Satan brother and uh but
yeah man I love that ain't no
misbehaving that's my running through
the aisle for the pickle and my refresh
it is too much sign too much yeah man
it's it's it's just a wild time has been
a lot going on this year there's been a
lot going on and I'm just feeling it
from a lot of people a lot of people
just wondering what about what's
happening right now
and I think it's because we're at that
lower than the final curve heading into
the end of the year because of the year
it's you know it's like anything it
gives us a shape it gives us a you know
the sink you're just you're just just
kind of oozing down the side of the sink
and then October hits and suddenly it
just crevasse is straight over towards
the drain and that's November December
and then BAM that's it and it's just
that time here where a lot is and
there's a lot energetically at stake
because we're heightened
and no I haven't been reading like some
horoscopes or anything like that cuz I
mean no damn starbursts a lot of these
you know you got these you know a lot of
people out here starbursts
and somebody you know they'll throw a
damn somebody will beat you in the head
with uh what is what a geode or
something you know a sock full of these
damn geodes and tell you you know you're
gonna go to heaven or whatever and these
you know who knows but it's just I don't
know what's going on so um yeah what
else what else is happening with me mmm
this weekend I didn't much watch the
Saints game I got sick actually I got a
little bit of the flu yesterday or two
days ago started to come on so there's
been kind of recovering from that so
some of this could be the nyquil talking
and uh yeah man that what I hate it
whenever you get the flu when you Hector
you're trying to blow your nose and like
you can't tell if the snot is trying to
go out or in so I'm doing some of this
it's like you know you're playing you're
just a dirty you're a dirty trombone and
you're playing yourself and and you're
just like what do I you know do I blow
it out do I get it through the back end
what am I doing here you almost want to
call somebody that's chimney sweeping
out there to come and take care of you
and beat you in the face or beat you in
the ass with a feather or something
something unique but if people see you
licking the air they will do it that's
that's what that's that's baffling
because you think people would see
somebody looking there to be like all
that guy you know calling the police but
instead what people see you out there
you get a friend to help they go lick
their first somebody be like oh look at
these guys huh
look at these freaks and then as they
walk away they'll kind of take a little
taste out of there and what is it what's
going on is they're they giving out free
ball is it Barry
let's go in alone
you don't know what's in the air
sometime now I remember my boy Jeffrey
saavy AK had a gas leak at his house
when I was young and they had on
monoxide or something and we would go we
didn't know we could fall asleep on the
Friday and wake up on Sunday beautiful
and be like damn do we the whole family
you walk through his kitchen his mom
would be just dad asleep doing us you
know you know five hours into making a
salad she you know she'd been asleep for
four four hours of 55 minutes of it just
so you know just different time but
beautiful you know beautiful to get that
free gas as a boy and this before the
legislation everybody got upset about
everything but get took just to get that
free gas as a boy man it was uh it was
nice it really was to go to a place and
get something for free there's just
something nice about it even if it is uh
kind of like a talks like our semi toxic
gas what else buddy of mine kind of get
me to invest with him in the zoo that's
crazy but I guess I've been lightly
considering it he got the read on our
zoo down in Sinaloa
I guess down in Mako so Sinaloa the
officially the estado libre he's sober I
know so that I know they seen alone um
okay kind of chatty there on Wikipedia
about it but yeah my buddy got a read on
a zoo that went under down there so I
don't know what to think about that you
know I got caught up in some bad
investments when I was young we did a
pyramid scheme and and and it made me
fight my peers actually so I guess I
don't know if that's what a pyramid
scheme is supposed to do but me and my
peers [ __ ] lost a bunch of money and
then we ended up
I'd love to know that actually if
anybody ever done a pyramid scheme and
got lost and what the fallout was from
it locally if he'd hit the hotline with
that I'm curious about that nine eight
five six six four nine five zero through
zero nine five zero three running
through the house with a pickle on your
mouth
ain't no misbehaving as wicked brah
that's that hot beat so anyway we'll see
man I don't know if a zoo is really
gonna beat my buddy said that um animals
are real hot in Mexico right now so but
I don't know that's just so we'll see
man if that's something that I can get
more information about because yeah I
did that we did glitter when I was young
like some dude came through you know you
know I'm not sure who it was but rolled
through town and got everybody into
glitter mining back when people thought
glitter was a um precious or
semi-precious stone and they popped and
they [ __ ] got us you know so people
you know I'm felling innocent you know
I've fallen in the dark financial waters
dude how his financial water is not a
name of a honestly a young urban
gentleman bro
that would be the best name ever but
yeah I don't know if suing her but any
malice is real popular my buddy said
down a Maiko
so we'll see bottom of getting involved
in a zoo down there is the best overall
use of of my earnings but it's a cool
down in the coolican coolican cooly
cooly Aachen province Culiacan see he
said this three point two one six
million down there people and that's as
of this year but who knows how many
knows people are hanging out staying
there but
but yeah man you got to think that out
of three point two one six million
people you only need how many people out
of zoo every week to make it function
and make money
I bet probably two thousand people so if
you can't get two thousand people to go
to a new zoo in Mexico out of three
point excuse me out of three point two
one six then are you even a business man
that's one of my big questions so we'll
see but I'll keep you guys posted what
else is happening oh I got the hair
that's what's been going on I'm like
what if I have been doing much I got the
hair rejuvenation again so you know I
love surgery and and I got it so I've
been having to chill that's been the
worst thing I've been having to
literally do nothing and then two days
ago I started getting sick so it's been
tough having you know they took it out
the back they took a decent crop and
they put it up in that front boy so here
in the bag here in the font so but it
take a while they just take the seed now
a lot of people do not know this and
I've talked about it before in here but
if you do the fue hair surgery now I go
to this bit this fellow doctor can out
here in Beverly Hills fancy guy I'm not
sure where he from do probably I don't
want to say maybe Middle East maybe
Antarctic I'm not sure do but like kind
of darker Antarctica
you know ant dark touka you know he's
just nothing you know he's uh he's a
Beverly Hills guy beautiful man and he
works in he worked in um in transplanter
II long before you know an actual organ
transplantation and now he does hair so
what they do they they shave the back
they take about maybe one out of every
12 hairs out of the back or 30 hairs or
something dig it out they have a little
bitty it's not like a shovel but it's
pretty much like a little bit like a
little you know
uncle baby billy shovel and they just
I mean they just run through the house
with a pickle in their mouth pulling
hairs out he is dumb but he if back down
back he ahead rear you know out of that
[ __ ] out of that big half dome in the
back out of that free solo freaking back
piece you know so they pull him out and
then they dig a little bitty holes in
the front and they have two nurses that
come take the hairs from the back put
him in the front and that's how it goes
it took about four or five hours they
give you a valium so I started watching
El Camino and then I woke up like an
hour and a half later and I was in a
watching a soap opera song you know what
the hell happened but El Camino didn't
seem that good honestly but um so I did
that did that dirty trick where and uh
and now it's been recovering the hard
part is you can't do anything active so
you can't do gym you can't do yoga you
have to sleep at a 45 degree angle like
a shitty uh you know like a someone
who's supposed to do you know like that
chubby guy on the night's watch or
whatever that guy's name is el it's not
Eldred but you know I'm talking about
the guy who's taking care of somebody
else's baby Smee or what Smeagol not
Smeagol
um but yeah you sleep at a 45 degree
angle you know like kind of like a
[ __ ] like a semi alert person I guess
like a somebody who sleepwalks but his
lazy said are not even doing it so
that's the tough part you got to stack
the pillows at a certain angle you got
to get the ruler or you can do a thing
on your phone now that shows you what
angles are so you got to get that
45-degree angle so I sleep at that
bastard and today was the first day I
could wash the back of the hair and just
pour a little water on the front and
that's been six or seven days five six
five six days so on Tuesday I'll be able
to resume I think some yoga and some
just moving around but it's sucked
because you get stagnant
you get stagnant and that's what hasn't
been good for me I don't like being
stagnant because when I'm not moving the
things around me I can be affected you
know this things can get me more the
world can get me more when I'm not
moving and so that's when you know I
think for me it's tough and that's when
I get caught thinking more about
honestly more about the dark arts
because you're just right there you know
if a vultures flying by and they got a
and they got a meat that's sitting right
there just a sitting meat then it's and
they have one meat that's rolling down
the hill you know a meat in motion then
that birds gonna get that sitting meat
that SM and that's what I feel like and
that's why I think it's just with this
time of year and this much you know
energy in the air it's like man I just
want to get moving again so I can you
know get out of some of these shadows
and stuff and just make sure I'll stay
stay in the light brother we're gonna be
part of the good stuff huh so yeah I got
the fue hair transplantation it's my
second time did I need it probably not
but you know I don't spend money on much
and I like having hair you know I like
having it now one scary thing the flood
the foam the flood the they inject your
scalp with a bunch of different saline
solution and a bunch of stuff to numb
the pain well this junk starts at the
second day and third day you don't
notice it but then on the fourth day
your forehead swells up then the
swelling rolls down your face
and you start to get swollen around your
eyes nose cheek if you're on the YouTube
but I'll include some photos you know
cuz I like to be candid about it I mean
I look like a panther I look like a
white panther I look like a um kind of
like a somebody a fat snake that's kind
of dumb a little at one point I look
like a fire boy a boy that'd have been
maybe not in a fire well maybe like a
boy who'd been in like a medium kind of
fire and no disrespect to anybody that's
in a fire or has been you know [ __ ]
least you've been in the fire bruh a lot
of people afraid even [ __ ] step
outdoors if things is getting real
Headey and at least you've been in the
fire what else do we have here I got a
cold man I'm still getting over this I
could even do my con I had two comedy
sets man um here's oh I'll tell you this
this message came in to me on Instagram
this boy
this is from from this boy said el Raton
if someone is trying to dress up like
you for Halloween what are some
essentials well first of all I think you
got to have if you're gonna be me you
definitely need to have some
antidepressants in your pocket gang bro
and if and after that I think you need
to
I'd go with body oil I'd go with the Rat
King attire
I'd go with body or at least one strap
you want to be strapped up I think you
need to have the dark glasses you need
to have that straight up that uncle baby
Billie backsplash that long hair in the
back you know that dirt curtain boy if
this necks are not if this necks are
knocking don't come a rock and you feel
me
you need to have D
in attitude nothing more than that you
know you don't ever you know you know to
be real fired up or keyed up you got to
just know that hey you know you [ __ ]
beat Chris D'Elia twice that's all you
got to know boy and that's the whole
outfit and go out there and have a loved
one you know preferably female keep
putting baby oil on you and you can put
the baby along on your face as well if
you don't have baby oil you can use
Crisco or um or butter unsalted butter
stick butter I prefer the stick bruh go
straight into your skin I don't like the
[ __ ] marjoram you got to rub it in
you get somebody to just rub that [ __ ]
just get somebody to rub that hot stick
on you and the stick will heat up the
more you rub it on your body because
that's one of the internal powers of
butter so that's one of uh you know
nature's beauties right there but yeah
what else dude we got the hair we got
the business opportunity ellaby sneeze
better 39 we got um what else we got
some calls that came in we got some new
merch it's gonna come out at the end of
the beginning of next week
a lot of gue lot of cool stuff if you
think about Christmas gifts or anything
like that at theof on comm slash store
and I'll tell you this that hiring can
be a slow process in hiring that's not a
Jewish name that is a that is a word
that's when you need somebody to help
you do something hiring can be a slow
process Cafe alturas Co Oh Dylan Miska
wit mich Mich go it's needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but he was having trouble
finding qualified applicants so he
switched to zip recruiters zip
recruiters doesn't depend on candidates
finding you that's insane
imagine that you're trying to sleep at
night they got a bunch of candidates you
know breaking any a house and and
stealing all you know stealing opera
opportunities from you that's freaking
that's freaking ludicrous brother it
finds them for you zip recruiters
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast and that's how Dylan
found his director of coffee in just a
few days with results like that it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day see why
zip recruiters effective for businesses
of all sizes try zip recruiter for free
at zip recruiter comm slash tpw that's
zip recruiter comm slash tpw zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and
there's no place that it gets spookier
for me than in my underpants boy my UPS
boy them you purrs some people say Upper
Peninsula dude I'm talking about under
Peninsula
it's Halloween is nothing spookier than
showing you your paint your peeny or
your virginity you know your veggetti to
somebody I mean just think about it dude
is there anything scarier looking in
your junk probably not so it's that time
of year where you could really really
get it right me undies they are offering
spooky soft junk covers yep they're
designed to be the best thing you've
ever put on your body softer than a
fluffy kitten running around you're nuts
I mean dang softer than the brains the
zombies like to eat or also some of some
of these brains zombies are on keto so
they won't eat your brain if you've been
thinking about potato chips the softest
undies
they run extra small to 4xl me undies
has the most unique prints out there one
fun thing to do would be to jump in a
bed at the end of the night and
trick-or-treat one last time and you're
frikkin and you you know your buddy's
underpants and you're in your buddy's
[ __ ] a little junk drawer around
their booty if you don't like leaving
your house that's cool
just wear the Halloween costumes to pass
out
candy and you're good me undies has
those as well they got the me undies
those onesies bro it's a no-brainer
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed dude if you if
you if you if you put on a bunch of me
undies you're satisfied get to get 15%
off your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction go to meet undies comm
slash weekend that's M II
und IES comm slash weekend and and get
those uncle baby bottom hit hers ya feel
me get them hitters baby take care of
your crotch and everything I'm gonna
pick some up they got some great ones
pumpkins little lanterns this and that
people get it right you know what I was
also thinking let's check in before we
get to the hotline
let's check in you guys remember uh
Danielle the virgin and she had
virginity and um and then she didn't
have it and it's been a year since we
communicated with her and and we're glad
that people have you know or someone at
that time had been inside of her body
and there's nothing more haunting than
letting someone in your body think about
it I mean you can go a lot of places you
can walk right in but if you just walk
right into somebody's body a lot of
times it's illegal so to let somebody
get in your body that's and you know
that's very there's nothing more
haunting than that that's a real I'm
gonna haunt you for a couple of seconds
with this Wayne or what you know I'm a
drape this for jet over you and haunt
you little you know how haunt your
little Peter area you get it so it's
been a year now that danielle has
allowed her body to be haunted by others
and so let's check in with her right
here and just see how it's going
hello hey Danielle hey hey what's up
it's Theo from the this past weekend I'm
doing pretty well
we're just how are you doing actually
we're just thinking I was thinking
actually I try to blame it on other
people but that it's been a year since
we had the the Danielle the Virgin call
yes yeah and what a year you know how's
it been it's that good it's actually at
the time of the initial call I lived in
Savannah and now I live in DC so that's
been a nice change of scenery look you
get some D and then you want you got a
you want to add letters to it you know
yeah what took you over there to DC well
I've been thinking of moving for a while
and actually kind of the catalyst was
the guy that I was dating the beat taker
if you will did it end so well so like
when that ended I was like well I'm
gonna get the heck out of Dodge you know
yeah and how is the um how's the sexual
Miss been once you got over to DC is it
different what's from Savannah to DC
[Music]
we're up here to be honest it's a little
bit harder to find people I find that a
lot of them are already buried more just
kind of like self-absorbed in a way no
the dating scene is a bit harder but you
know it's not that hard
yeah well it's not that hard to get
somebody to just falling in here in your
body if you need them to I guess yeah
not not too hard when you really tried
yeah can you feel any different now that
you're you know a part of the sexual
community
I guess I mean I feel like I'm kind of
in on uh you know like a secret although
I guess it's not a secret like the
majority of people have sex so it's like
the worst kept secret yeah but yeah I
just kind of like I get what it's about
I feel like there's a new topic of
discussion that can be had that's cool
too so yeah I like that yeah and um do
you know have you learned I like what
have you learned about sex do you feel
like anything I don't even cuz I don't
know [ __ ] I've been doing it fairly you
know for a long time but I've been doing
it but I mean it's just kind of like a
natural thing you know there's only so
many things you can do yeah um but I
mean learns not really honestly yeah
yeah no I mean not not really I think
it's just kind of you go with the flow I
mean I guess there's like obviously
positions and stuff like right but I
think it's just it's only a couple
though that matter yeah yeah I mean yeah
it's like are we on land are we you know
what you know it's very there's only so
much humans can do without you know
being you know having you know gasoline
involved or getting re you know somebody
jumping off a dam building or something
you know yeah there's so many there's
only so many faith options yeah yeah and
do you have things escalated now or you
go have you gotta join any sexual groups
have you did you then want to get in
like threesomes and stuff like that has
it gotten pretty um has it gotten kind
of spooky or anything um I can't say
I've done any of that okay
spooky I mean I guess so I mean the when
the first time we spoke you talked about
like but action and that has happened so
I just feel like oh well have been
checked so that's the thing yeah and so
was that something that you brought upon
yourself
or was that something that was initiated
by a young man um it was
he says accidentally initiated but I
don't believe that yeah I didn't believe
that for a second I was just like yeah
keep going oh wow
but yeah so I was just like let's not
talk about this cuz it's already
happening so let's just keep with the
flow okay um so yeah that was well that
escalated quickly
it really did cuz it was within like
three weeks with the same the guy who
like it was the same person dude yeah I
just wanted it all oh I'll tell you this
I'm a guy and that's how it goes okay
yeah you know well we'll mill around you
for a couple weeks until we accidentally
try to fall into your but you know yeah
and then sometimes it works yeah and
sometimes it works um well thanks Eddie
do you wish you were still a virgin are
you okay you know it's it is what I mean
it's better not being one I mean I'm
having more fun yeah oh yeah and it
looks like you kind of took it you know
it's like you kind of rain you know it's
like you don't want to be because how
old are you now 26 yeah yeah I don't
think I have a friend I think who got
married and she's might be like 40 or
something she's a virgin at that point
it's like you kind of scare it's you
know you're starting to scare people
some yeah I mean I felt that way at 25
so I can only imagine what it is you
know yeah at 40 that's a lot at 40 I
think you just save it go back to heaven
yeah at that point it's like let's get
all the brownie points with Jesus yeah
Wow so one year out there on the sex
circuit Danielle that's beautiful yeah
you know one year down hopefully many to
come oh yeah oh yeah you can [ __ ] for at
leisure do sex or whatever you want to
do for at least probably forty years
I've been 40 well yeah I guess unless
you know barring any tragedy yeah yeah
well yeah yeah I hope it doesn't happen
um what do you
to be for Halloween what are we gonna be
for hollow besides a real [ __ ] you feel
me I mean if you're doing what
activities with somebody that's
Halloween basically he you have to be an
L wait Halloween is basically the bud
sex of the calendar great way to put it
but I guess since I celebrate it like
regularly yeah it's like not a big not a
big deal the day of you know yeah oh wow
you're unbelievable but it's so good to
hear you sound good is everything going
okay yeah it's going good it's um just
night it's nice Sunday evening here in
DC so yeah it's um going pretty well
yeah just you know 20 year old or in my
20s living life you know yes
staying damp out there in those meat
streets huh yeah you well good luck to
you know just don't get in keep doing
any wild drugs or anything like that
that's when it can get really really
wild you know oh no I think I mean
that's already happened oh damn yeah
sorry well let you down there how about
this hey stay alive try and stay alive
if you can't yes I will do that I love
it it's my ability and it's nice to hear
your voice saying you'll hope you have a
good day and I'm glad you've had a safe
year of decent sex you know or
semi-decent
thank you so much Theo I appreciate it
yep good luck out there and I hope to
see in the future awesome thank you I'm
looking forward to whenever you get
Maryland rescheduled yes so am i okay
but a lot of people asking about it I
think it's gonna be at the very end of
January so but I'll let y'all let you
no soon Oh awesome that sounds great
yeah yeah we'll put it on the books or
something this week I think so we'll
have a good Sunday even and I'll talk to
you later
thank you alright then your bike and
just like that and just like that people
are coming into the back door of our
lives the spirits are out there they'll
find any way into you so your face
through your eyes do you snap through
your buttocks Wow
it escalates quickly doesn't it that's
okay man that's okay she sounds like
she's doing well though she's telling
she's doing well and so I'm glad that
she called that that she answered Thank
You Danielle let's take a couple of
calls here they hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three hey Theo this is Terri just
calling in cuz I was watching your show
hey thanks for calling in Terri and I
would love to tell you that that that
that's my favorite name but it is not
but that has nothing to do with you as a
human you're different than your name on
what the guy named Griffin called in
about his girlfriend breaking up after a
while I just wanted to reach out to him
and let him know that things get better
and it's just going to take a little
time but there's light at the end of the
tunnel dude you just got to look for it
and focus on yourself right now for a
while you haven't been able to focus on
yourself because there's been able
you've been in a relationship but now
you got so texting yourself and you can
really improve on some things and but
gets a lot better man I promise all
right
and neither that's that's a thanks for
calling with that Terry and that's a
good suggestion too and when you're in a
relationship you can't see you it's hard
cuz you had that all do you got that
accomplice you know you got that human
side that human you know you got that
adjacent human
and you can't see you can't just see you
I mean it's harder because when you look
in the mirror both you guys are there to
get there's a team and you know it's
tough it's tough to know what's a good
relationship what's a safe amount of
them involved in you what's a healthy
amount not sable what how healthy is it
I mean look I struggle so much in this
space I don't even I think it's nice
that this call came in though I'll tell
you this about the the listeners of this
experiment that we probably got I would
bet 200 calls for that for for
suggestions for Griffin so that I mean
that's amazing to me that they hear that
somebody struggling and that that many
calls came in for him
here's another one that came in Thank
You Terry oh we have a good day vo sup
your boy mark the Sacramento area of
California right now I'm listening to
your podcast just dropped in a young man
with a shaky broken voice is talking
about losing a relationship at three and
a half years
yeah that's Griffin they called in and
thanks for calling him brother from
Sacramento and Sacramento the home of
the missing people actually a lot of
missing people up there in that area so
hope you're you know you know you know
you're checked in with others on word
and take an ownership like you ought to
and that's good
I'd like to give him some advice there's
a guy that's going through some really
bad times in his own marriage first of
all go ahead and grieve cry don't get
drunk and don't go and score okay don't
go don't go out and chase Huynh you
don't do that just breathe breathe cry
process this and after you've done that
go get a counselor to start talking to
someone once a month and just deal with
your stuff be honest be transparent be
ugly honest deal with your issues
because when love comes around
and you need to have this stuff in check
and you can do it bro you absolutely can
gang man thank you there I think that
was a smart Bo what's up your boy mark
yeah thank you thank you very much mark
for that call man that stuff resonates
with me to what you're saying mark cuz
uh you know I find that I carry the same
problems from my past and I continue to
carry him into my future in
you know and it's like I I don't know I
just sometimes think I would be able to
learn a little bit better even for me
and I know that this young man is
struggling and I think that that's the
this is a good suggestion find somebody
to talk to
and be brutally honest you know so no we
don't want to be brutally honest man I
don't you know we
want to be brutally honest how scary
would it be to just tell it just to be
just it's crazy we will live our life in
lye
we will live our life's in lie before we
will be brutally honest I will I have
and that's the dark arts man and it's
crazy because the dark arts a lot of
times it's our truth and there really
the brightest thing in the room but the
things that separate us from them or the
things that we choose instead of them
are the ways that we satiate
no I don't know she's got a little loss
there but but yeah that's a good
suggestion is that if there were real
issues in your relationship Griffin then
you can yeah if you would you here's the
thing you'll take the same ones into the
next relationship that's not gonna
change
that's not gonna change you know I see
my therapist about different issues that
I have and and sometimes I don't want to
find them I don't want to battle them
I'm tired man sometimes I am I don't
want to do it I don't want to do the
hard work sometimes
I know what it is I know it's right
there but sometimes it's just it's hard
man sometimes it's hard
and the scary thing is some of the
truths women you know what they are but
we can just feel them
I'm feeling milling around behind the
corner behind our shoulders you know but
take care of yourself do your best
Griffin you know keep people out of your
butt that's always a safe place to start
and you know and that's what we we just
we deal with in the meantime you know we
deal with in the meantime because a lot
of a lot of life is that it's in the
meantime what do we do before you know
just take care of yourself right now you
know you got some fellows that a lot of
people that reached out with suggestions
so thank you to everybody that called in
here's a call that came in to the
hotline Oh word what's going on Donna
what's up Playboy get at me daddy gang
gang this is Dylan Armstrong at a bottom
Texas DA down in Bonham bruh [ __ ] with
me I'm 25 I did pest control thing done
for about two years
praise God brother PG son PTL baby
appraisal art and damn I hate a pastor
bro I hate a past so just knowing that
you out there brah yes just gonna in
these little [ __ ] Muppets down cuz a
pestle do anything where you close the
door pest come right up under that [ __ ]
you have a couple bananas out in the
morning and they got six or seven little
flies on that [ __ ] trying to suck it
off what like damn man they don't stop
you come home sometime you have a couple
of roaches over there and listen to me a
stereo bruh and they [ __ ] they don't
care they doing coke off your iPad it
never ends boy these pests brah you know
you you know you'll be a richer window
and a couple NT for try to sneak in that
[ __ ] bra skirts get them drown them out
boy hit him with a little bit of [ __ ]
wd-40 or something you know or a little
bit of roundup-ready bra so I'm glad to
know guys like you
out there all worked no I think seven
years ago I was you know cooking at
tonic and so from then on come up to
this you know time now seven years later
or whatever I've been constantly trying
to better my goals and get you know
better job and heart stuff Amen man so
for ya if he's cooking in Sonic and now
you doing pest control man it's good
because you're taking you know it's
definitely more job where you were
you're out there interacting with people
now you know you have much more
responsibilities with pest control cuz
you got to show up you got to have the
chemicals mixed you got to have your
appointments on target sonic who gives a
[ __ ] dude you in there shooting up
somebody wants a muffin you show up to
the front of the register and deal with
that [ __ ] you know unless they still
doing a roller skates or whatever I
haven't been there in a while but if you
got a chick you know you got a cherry
ice a couple of mothers out there you
know and you got them roller skates on
bro I mean I don't know how sonic even
stayed in business with the roller
skates shut it down man because people
I'm you know you got a you know you got
a dollar a dollar 60 150 sandwich and
somebody's on rollers somebody's trying
to [ __ ] are skating that [ __ ] out the
door the chance of them dying or getting
hurt or breaking her neck for a dollar
fifty you know a little stacker this the
insurance has got to be through the roof
and especially some of the Sonic's
brother in dangerous neighborhoods so
you [ __ ] you got that cherry lime you
know when a cut and a handful of [ __ ]
snack poppers and you're trying to sneak
out you know you're trying to you on
wheels and you ducking and [ __ ]
bullets you know it's just [ __ ] gets
real shifty out there when you're trying
to sonic up and they got them too you
know you know there's two men there's
you know a couple of you know those two
gay gentleman they're beautiful guys on
doing all the commercials and they over
there [ __ ] hiding from their wives
and putting poppers in each other's
mouths
dude and you could tell the one guy's on
uppers the little white one he's on he's
on some type of a little you know dust
poppers or something and he hits it
right when he catches that you know when
he catches that backdoor [ __ ] stage
pipe so it's you know you know what I'm
saying bro it is what it is man but I'm
glad you're staying busy dude I'll tell
you this about pest controls I used to
like when a mosquito truck would come
man
God that [ __ ] was Christmas brought from
my lungs and brain because when that
mosquito truck would rolled through and
I grew up down there you know in that
rural area skate ski or they got ski
does well skeet is a lot of skeeters
from even different countries would come
and do summer homes in our area and so
you know a lot of um when this guy when
that mosquito truck the city once a year
maybe like six times a year they would
spray something out of the back of our
van and sometimes it was like this spray
gun and sometimes it was just you know a
couple bad [ __ ] and a gay gentleman
back there where the UM you know a
couple bad [ __ ] with um just some
spray canisters of it and they just
holding the van they just rolling down a
street you know
repellent they called it repellent
repellent and we ride our bikes behind
that just nose-first boy
just catching that hit rather there was
nothing better than that free hi out
there you half our neighborhood people's
parents stepparents children
stepchildren double-step you know people
do not people that wasn't even living
they would be in a coffin and their
[ __ ] cousins pushing them down the
street catching that [ __ ] that
freaking hot hit off the city brought
that Skeeter hit you know that repple
and boy that [ __ ] yeah hot dude dude
after half a block I didn't [ __ ] know
who I was anymore did I remember I
remember after two blocks I didn't
listing a damn military bro told him my
name was Benedict Arnold one time and
tried to enlist bro so I'm just saying
this uh you know pest control is a
beautiful I'd say it's a premiere
position in a lot of areas so sorry I'm
rambling man let's go on and with you
been where you're at how you have so
much stuff going on all at once I was
just kind of wondering did it ever get
to a time or do you ever get to
experience kind of just chill time
because when I said I've been going for
about seven years straight and I'm
constantly trying to get you know better
opportunities and it's kind of hard to
sit back and enjoy it anyway man keep
doing what you're doing
Gang Gang Gang brother thanks for
listening to man I really appreciate
that you know I worry sometimes I don't
ever want to be you know I just want to
be the same I want to be I want to
always know I'm just glad that you
listen thank you uh you know I think
I've noticed this some people you just
always are gonna find the next thing and
that's just who you are you're always
gonna find the next thing
as soon as I got here now I want to know
here okay
now I got to this stair now I want to go
and that's just it's just built into you
you know relaxation for you is almost
you know it's it's uh well not
relaxation but ambition some people
ambition okay I'm talking about
something different or me less an
ambition that's never gonna change if
you have ambition if you start at one
job and you find yourself wanting to do
another job and then you start to see
okay now I have this kind of skillset
mastered now how do I you know by my own
pest control company or how do i you
know how do I get myself a to pest
control trucks on my own and then just
you know in a couple employees and and
yeah basically starting your own pest
control company how do I go from being
an employee to being an employer and
that's ambition that I don't think that
ever leaves you I think that thing just
stays that was that was putting you
that's a pilot light that was leading to
you by the Lord or by your family or by
somebody will threw a match any a [ __ ]
[ __ ] as a child you know and that
never changes but I believe that uh that
sometimes we have to slow it down and
you know this year I really have
struggle with that man I got in over my
head with busyness and uh I was just
stressed out man
and so I've had it slowed it down I
better just cut back on the
responsibilities you know we've had less
guest episodes on the podcast I had to
take some comedy dates off the books and
I was gonna lose my mind I was losing my
hair and your hair bro your hair is just
a soft strands of roof right out of your
mind so I knew if that [ __ ] was falling
out the next thing to fall my [ __ ]
brain bro you know I go to bust a hard
fart or something in my brains in the
toilet I mean it just the propensity
for me to continue to do well at the
point of stress that I was personally
feeling was really tough let me listen
to the any of your question one more
time and going about seven years
straight and I'm constantly trying to
get you know better opportunities and
it's kind of hard to sit back and enjoy
it anyway man keep going it is hard to
sit back and enjoy it and you kind of
don't in a way you know I noticed a
little bit a lot of the work than what
some of us are because I was never
really that great and enjoying things
anyway in this part of my alcoholism for
me my autism always wants my this got to
be the next thing you know I'd be at a
party and and it would be the party and
I'd be odd I'd hear a rumor I'd even
[ __ ] make up a rumor I'd hear a rumor
there was a better party somewhere and I
started probably that room when I got to
that party I started a rumor hey there's
a much better party over then an hour
later that party would come that that
rumor would hit me at the same party hey
man her and I'm like [ __ ] man we had to
go to that party and I just there was
nothing was ever okay I ever good enough
because I was never okay so just never
okay was my thing and so I couldn't
enjoy things I could never really enjoy
something and some of us you just might
be that way your joy may come from
staying busy it may be the place where
you feel best now if you do find
yourself real stressed out you got to
take something off the docket man and as
far as new opportunities and growth and
jobs and stuff I noticed those things
happen for me as as I was as as I would
do something new now you're working in
pest control which first of all thank
you bro people don't think how much pest
is out there and that that people don't
think that every morning they got you
know two three thousand seven thousand
em efforts out there beautiful I'm Afra
sorry
going out there to fight past bro dude
what
that's insane Jesus I mean there's no
great there's no greater battler of the
Dark Arts then then somebody who's
fighting pest think about different
pests dude bats snakes attack snakes
roaches vermin never ends pass vague
could be anybody bran it could be
illegal aliens dude to some in some
areas okay but you know the term pest is
insane it could be somebody sneaking
down your chimney trying to steal a log
or [ __ ] you know knock your wife up
or whatever you know people you know
people come in your house for different
reasons but but nobody think about how
much a pest a man how thank you is what
I'm saying thank you for your service
dude cuz nobody thinks about that right
you guys sleep in for a couple of weeks
the [ __ ] world will be overrun with
spiders scorpions manta rays uh what am
I thinking of [ __ ] uh I can't think
of it
Oh everything so but I hear what I was
saying when I noticed was once I started
to work in new circles and get a little
bit higher then I was communicating with
people who are working in new circles so
once I thought I was just a comedian
then I was like uh oh now I'm doing have
we doing a podcast now I'm talking with
other people that are doing podcasts so
now they know more information and I can
ask them hey how did you get from here
to here what do I need to do that so
it's tough to know if you're talking
about ambition or if you're talking
about overworked if you're being
overworked man and I don't know if you
ever will enjoy it
because ambition sometimes keeps us from
enjoying things and someone keeps me
because I'm always finding that next
horizon even if I don't want to I think
ambition is something that is just in
you sometimes I don't know if it's
really a choice a lot of times but it's
funny I do think certain experiences
will unlock because I didn't know I had
really done much ambition sometimes I
don't thing but I'll say this man thank
you for your service and and keep going
you know it's always okay now I'm an
employer and then okay somebody's in
them I'm an employee how do I find out
how do I be that employer or how do I
see you know who's the guy that brings
the chemicals to the pest-control every
week who's that guy because I really
like his job I really like what he does
that's a field I really could see myself
in or who's the guy that sells the the
pest control companies the two people
you know who sells up and I can't think
what it's called franchise who's the guy
who sells the franchises to different
people and that's it now that's it see
it just you know as you get up there
little as you get up the ladders you'll
see you just you can see more you can
see different views and the ladders are
there for everybody
I believe that man I really do
here's the call that came in ninety five
six six four nine five zero three hey
you know it's Mike from bite abuse
trying to be a farmer but kind of
struggling now a farm oh thank you
Michael
and thank you for calling him Annie no I
work on a coid soybean corn and cotton
farm over in Natchez Mississippi
actually I worked for the father of the
man who saw him we heard on the way in
shine by Bishop Gunn was that song and
his father employed me over there on the
banks of the Mississippi home work kind
of struggling you know I'll farm and
can't pay the bills anymore
but until you become pretty much a super
farmer Farm thousand acres out of 40
acres my brother he's already successful
farms 1500 and he
yes dream and I want to keep the dream
to fly myself trying to juggle it with
worth I work 60 hours a week as it is
and tried to get time off the farm and I
had to go into a meeting with my boss
that he said he won't allow it so I
don't know if I should dive headfirst
and just start farming and live off
ramen her if I keep my job he's really
good you know it might not be successful
because I'm not all in it on the side
and I don't know you got any advice on
what to do I'd appreciate it
and if you ever want to do some farming
come up here gang bro I'll come up there
dude I'll grow about 700 acres of
cocaine run you know I'm saying
you feel me dude or that grow cane you
feel me boy you know what I'm talking
about that sue Corrigan Oh Papa that
sugar cane that straight ball baby you
got it the James Harden of the garden
son this [ __ ] will cross you over this
[ __ ] I'll just have you double dribbling
your own ideas boy that's that hitter
and I got that from Maui right there
some of y'all know that I mean you want
to talk about Mother Nature's land
dandruff baby you got it
this thing will have you beaten the
street with your snout son just that
hitter bamboo bought a gram boo this is
that suka right that guy who cry you
know you throw this enough and a drug
addict I'll come back with it in his
mouth
you could stay off a cocaine and stay
off on that grow cane baby you know what
I'm saying this that that [ __ ] scary
pot or dog Petrificus Totalus
this uh do look oh oh man Oh woohoo you
saw they're looking for me bro you know
what I'm saying I'll suck your stick
you know that's tasty man
oh that's tasty and only nature offers
that sweet you know but yeah this also
gonna do diabetes to you as well if you
have too much of it you know this should
have put the beat and diabetes dude
let's give you that hiya biddies dog you
know you'd be you know kind of just you
know blowing your knee but for a couple
of you know for a little bit of that
that Graham boo you feel me going bro
but what I'm saying is man don't do
drugs you know they're safer drugs out
there now sugars just as addictive I
will say it but but uh but you never
really seem to do blowing a guy for a
Cinnabon so you got to think about that
you know big picture and only in my we
do to have such a beautiful creature and
other places actually Louisiana also has
this Vietnam as well but only really
unique and special spots can offer you
know can the land just make such a damn
drug and and God dang it's beautiful
that when you see sugar in its natural
form isn't it you don't think about I
like this do you you don't think every
time you bite a cookie that there's a
little bit of forest in it do you that
Mother Nature's just lurking inside of
that cookie and about you to about you
get you get you a stick did and you bout
to be her little cookie [ __ ] and a
sugar cane boy and girl sorry
woo that thing gets me fired up dude you
know natural sweets get me fired up but
thank you for that opportunity to come
over there and farm I really appreciate
that man up I want to I want to I want
to say this man you know there comes a
time where it's like yeah you have to
decide and you know what a lot of people
don't do what they really want to do
you know the two things that made me
happiest man in my life one time the the
happiest day ever had actually I know
for this for a fact the happiest time
ever had I was working at a disabled
children farm in India and I can't even
believe they had this [ __ ] they had
children you know doing they were
disabled they got him [ __ ] farming
[ __ ] this shipment it might have been
illegal I don't know but I went there
with a school trip and we were supposed
to work there and help out it and we did
and it was amazing man and it was one
day of my life right us felt man I felt
a spirit inside of me that was stronger
than just me I felt a something inside
of me that was very real you know and I
think it was connection it was purpose
um you know it sounds like if your
brother's doing farming you would always
have a way into the industry so that's
nice oh and it sounds like you also may
you're just not sure if you want to do
it he said you said you have a good job
right now and it's paying well here in
the beginning if you said you wanted
from buy the booze trying to be a farmer
but kind of struggling you know our
farming campaign the bills anymore
okay so farming can't pay the bills
unless you're a part of a super farm you
said and yeah it sounds like maybe you
just want to be but you also you want to
make money and it's tough man you know
my brother runs a um
he runs a premier tree service and
landscaping service and really almost an
environmental service at this point down
in Baton Rouge and it's called Biggs bi
ggz and he started off as a tree cutter
he was a cutter for someone he'd cut in
trees and he's got some great stories or
any cut into a beehive once and oh but
then one day he said I could I why am i
working for this guy can be this guy
that I'm working for so then he became
that guy and next thing you know he he
got the knowledge he needed to go with
the job and he was a foreman and he was
running a couple guys who were climbing
trees and he was then booking the
business
and then he went back to school and got
a doctorate so now the dude you know
he's like a damn you know he's the
Fibonacci of ferns brah I mean this dude
you know he's the who's that guy you
know doctor you know he's the Kevorkian
of [ __ ] of pines and evergreens
right he'll you know he just he knows
what he's doing so then now he has a
bigger business and it just and the
faith at because you know what I want to
be sometimes sometimes I just want to
work for my brother there's a big part
of my heart that just wants to work for
him
I want to ride in a truck and I want to
go to the worksite and I want to do what
he needs me to do
and sometimes I think that that would
make me really happy now I don't know
that's the case I mean also have
alcoholism that'll trick your brain and
the things that will make you happy that
won't but I think it's a real part of me
that wants that and that's fair that's
okay
you know that's fair there so sometime
we just have a part you know it made us
be part of you that wants to farm and
maybe something you do later once you've
made enough money to kind of satiate you
and make you comfortable and then you
can get into it more but I will say this
don't live a life if you can help it
beating yourself up for not being a
farmer I think every man in some way
wants to be a farmer
think every man wants to be a farmer man
all of us want to grow and create and
we're at a tough time in the world right
now because we're in between in this
time where we have we had so many
natural abilities and things that we're
doing as men and then now we we don't
use the skills as much anymore because
they're not as needed but for a lot of
people they are still needed and it's
beautiful out there in Iowa dude Dubuque
is beautiful I ran into a guy who told
me he was a pickpocket right over there
by the river brah truly beautiful man
one of my favorite hotels is over there
is haunted too as well but just don't
beat yourself up if you're not a farmer
right now you have a lot of time and who
knows the way things are going bro it
could be the only job available in a
couple of years you know it could be the
only thing that we're doing it could be
you know it'd be great if we're all out
there growing together every day huh
there'd be something beautiful about it
um and don't let anybody make you feel
bad if you're not a farmer you know
that's okay maybe you were working in
banking or something and one day you'll
give you'll create a business with your
brother and you guys can merge the
businesses and then you can do some
farming actually because you'll be
loaning to his business or something or
you'd be able to do consulting or you
just don't know you don't know exactly
where you're gonna end up but I think
that we end up a lot of times most of us
do somewhere near where our heart and
our desires want us to be at some point
I believe that because even our desires
in our what we want are like these
ghosts kind of aren't they
I can always feel a ghost inside of me
kind of haunt haunting me with
things that would make me truly happy I
think and I'm glad you have a brother
man that's a beautiful gift I'm glad you
have a brother uh let's take one more
call right here I wanted to get into
more but um here let's see what we can
do nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three hey Co is seven here
from North suburbs of Chicago what's up
Kevin thank you for calling in man
and you know I love Illinois brother my
mother's born over there about 50 miles
from Peoria in beautiful state thank you
for calling you brought up how you know
sometimes you drive in Ohio and you just
start masturbating yep yeah I brought
that up man it's kind of tough to hear
that back from somebody and I did that
you know I was doing well with you know
battling the dark hearts had it
afflicted me and next thing you know is
in Ohio last week and I just I couldn't
really help myself all word and this
past weekend my dad and I drove to
Cleveland for the Browns game oh nice
man yeah that's awesome beautiful city
I'll tell you what man I hadn't
masturbated and sometimes a couple weeks
possibly more I don't really take a
tally but as soon as we got in that
hotel in Toledo for the night I found
myself in the bathroom and you know what
I was doing brother so I don't know man
maybe there's something going on I
appreciate it
gang gang gang bro you know that's
that's a good question maybe there's
something going on in Ohio
you know maybe it makes sense you get
there to the middle of the country and
you want to bust out and you want to
bust heavy and you want to spray full
and you want to fill the lane you want
to farm almost you want to plant your
freakin American flag right there in the
middle of that Ohio I don't know it's a
good question I wish we knew where a lot
of the masturbation was happening and
yeah I've been struggling with it man
and it's the pornography that does it I
don't jerk off for nothing bro it's the
pornography that leads me into it
but I wonder I'm glad you I'm glad you
told me that because they yeah I feel
less alone from that man so thank you
dude because there's nothing sadder than
thinking you're the only person that's
beating off all the time you know God
and I thought hey maybe we'll get into
that more next episode
[Music]
yeah what else man what else let's take
a call right here what's going on here
this your boy beanie from Jacksonville
Florida would IBD so my girl was born in
Romania and she goes back there every
now and then but since we've been
together we haven't spent the single day
apart wow that's that's intense man old
word now she had to go to Romania to get
some dental work done and she's gone for
a month
damn huh getting that Romanian D work
huh that ROM Michele [ __ ] fronts that
ROM myself front for defense Brooke gang
over for about two weeks in now and I'm
losing my mind
boredom has kicked in I can't can't wait
for her to be back so I know you ain't
in a relationship but you've been in a
few so what do you do to curb the
loneliness to make you feel like that
you've got somebody even though they're
10,000 miles away anyway just call them
to see your perspective garyun bro
man you know what's funny is that the
answers are almost the same things that
people were suggesting for Griffin it's
a good time for you to know yourself
you know it's a good time for you to get
to know yourself man it's funny that a
lot that missing said that like when
someone else has gone that suddenly when
were just with ourselves we feel so
lonely that's the thing that's just
always amazing to me how lonely I feel
when it's just me
that's uh and that for that for me
that's the that's the thing I'm trying
to solve well I feel that well I feel
that loneliness when it's just me
and that I think is some we're all
trying to solve
I don't know maybe I'm getting too met
or bait or I don't know what those words
mean but maybe I'm just I don't know
I've been kind of you know I've been
able to move around this week that much
but yeah I think I know not to not to
say you know I'm glad you called me and
I think but I think you know this is a
good time for you to get to know
yourself as not someone just who misses
their girlfriend or someone who's just
half of a relationship you who are you
you know it's a good question man it's
something you know we I feel like that's
one of the things we should know so much
more it feels like you know you know two
generations ago those men had more of an
idea of who they were you know to think
that men went off to Wars and went off
to all these experiences and left their
families and gave their a lot it's just
like there's so much I don't know
there's and now we have all these things
that make us that occupy our time and
take away our attention from us getting
to know ourselves really and each other
really so maybe this is a gift or you
get to know yourself man and your girls
coming back with that new freaking smile
bruh that [ __ ] Romanian you know
definitely you know that Romanian piano
brought that front piece that [ __ ]
six seven defense bruh she's gonna be
bringing that [ __ ] in here [ __ ]
living room so
um thank you guys for tuning in man
[Music]
thank you guys for tuning in yeah man we
don't know we're doing our best people
are jerking off in Cleveland
you know Griffin is trying to get
through it
somebody's named Terry you know somebody
wants to farm and they walk into an
office every day you know some guys
trying to quietly masturbate while his
father's in the hotel room next door
this is where we are man this is where
we are as men I guess in some ways but
we're on the come-up and there's a lot
to be learned right now the doors are
open you can have one hand in the future
in one hand in the past if you want you
can have one hand on the Lord and one
hand on the devil there's a lot going on
and this is the middle ground and I
believe that I really really believe
that I'm gonna leave you out here with
this song by Coley Garrett and this song
is English gothic thank you guys for
being a part of this and thank you guys
for being a part of my week man this was
the best part of the whole week was
being right here with you guys and gang
gang be good to yourselves you deserve
it and we just keep going
it's the best we can do for us it's the
best we can do for others
yeah we just can't get to don't we just
can't get to stagnant you can get still
that's okay we just don't get stagnant
you know sorry I'm not trying to preach
at you
just do your best man that's all I'm
doing gang English gothic by Coley
garage how to talk time to stay
everything though everything turns away
I will sing this song
[Music]
maybe we'll meet with us on my falls ha
nah it's not about and star couldn't
take it down the cold embrace
[Music]
I don't
I just walk inside the strangers hoping
[Music]
Kangra
I can't hear knives on the stone
I can't hear them distant awful this is
the heart coming home
[Music]
I just wanna walk inside this juicy